it is a really interesting to think
about like what the puzzle of the
universe is that the creator of the
universe uh give us a message like for
example in the book contact
UM Carl Sagan uh there's a message for
Humanity for any civilization in uh
digits in the expansion of Pi and base
11 eventually which is kind of
interesting thought uh maybe maybe we're
supposed to be giving a message to our
creator maybe we're supposed to somehow
create some kind of a quantum mechanical
system that alerts them to our
intelligent presence here because if you
think about it from their perspective
it's just say like Quantum field Theory
massive like cellular automaton like
thing and like how do you even notice
that we exist you might not even be able
to pick us up in that simulation and so
how do you how do you prove that you
exist that you're intelligent and that
you're a part of the universe so this is
like a touring test for intelligence
from Earth yeah like the Creator is uh I
mean maybe this is like trying to
complete the next word in a sentence
this is a complicated way of that like
the Earth is just is basically sending a
message back you yeah the puzzle is
basically like alerting the Creator that
we exist or maybe the puzzle is just to
just break out of the system and just uh
you know stick it to the Creator in some
way yeah basically like if you're
playing a video game you can um
you can somehow find an exploit and find
a way to execute on the host machine in
the arbitrary code there's some uh for
example I believe someone got Mario a
game of Mario to play Pong just by uh
exploding it and then
um creating a basically writing writing
code and being able to execute arbitrary
code in the game and so maybe we should
be maybe that's the puzzle is that we
should be um
uh find a way to exploit it so so I
think like some of these synthetic ads
will eventually find the universe to be
some kind of a puzzle and then solve it
in some way and that's kind of like the
end game somehow do you often think
about it as a as a simulation so uh as
uh the universe being a kind of
computation that has might have bugs and
exploits yes yeah I think so is that
what physics is essentially I think it's
possible that physics has exploits and
we should be trying to find them
arranging some kind of a crazy quantum
mechanical system that somehow gives you
buffer overflow somehow gives you a
rounding error in the floating Point uh
uh
yeah that's right and like more and more
sophisticated uh exploits like those are
jokes but that could be actually very
close yeah we'll find some way to
extract infinite energy for example when
you train reinforcement learning agents
um in physical simulations and you ask
them to say run quickly on the flat
ground they'll end up doing all kinds of
like weird things
um in part of that optimization right
they'll get on their back leg and they
will slide across the floor and it's
because of the optimization the
enforcement learning optimization on
that agent has figured out a way to
extract infinite energy from the
friction forces and basically their poor
implementation and they found a way to
generate infinite energy and just slide
across the surface and it's not what you
expected it's just a it's sort of like a
perverse solution and so maybe we can
find something like that maybe we can be
that little
dog in this physical simulation the the
cracks or escapes the intended
consequences of the physics that the
Universe came up with we'll figure out
some kind of shortcut to some weirdness
yeah and then oh man but see the problem
with that weirdness is the first person
to discover the weirdness like sliding
in the back legs
that's all we're going to do yeah it's
very quickly because everybody does that
thing so like the the paper clip
maximizer is a ridiculous idea but that
very well you know could be what then
we'll just uh we'll just all switch that
because it's so fun well no person will
Discover it I think by the way I think
it's going to have to be uh some kind of
a super intelligent AGI of a third
generation
like we're building the first generation
AGI you know
third generation yeah so the the
Bootloader for an AI the that AI yeah
will be a Bootloader for another AI yeah
and then there's no way for us to
introspect like what that might even uh
I think it's very likely that these
things for example like say you have
these agis it's very like for example
they will be completely inert I like
these kinds of sci-fi books sometimes
where these things are just completely
inert they don't interact with anything
and I find that kind of beautiful
because uh they probably they've
probably figured out the meta game of
the universe in some way potentially
they're they're doing something
completely beyond our imagination
um and uh they don't interact with
simple chemical life forms like why
would you do that so I find those kinds
of ideas compelling what's their source
of fun what are they what are they doing
what's the sourceful solving in the
universe
but inert so can you define what it
means inert so they escape
as in um
they will behave in some very like
strange way to us because they're uh
they're beyond they're playing the
metagame uh and The Meta game is
probably say like arranging quantum
mechanical systems in some very weird
ways to extract Infinite Energy uh solve
the digital expansion of Pi to whatever
amount uh they will build their own like
little Fusion reactors or something
crazy like they're doing something
Beyond Comprehension and uh not
understandable to us and actually
brilliant under the hood what if quantum
mechanics itself is the system and we're
just thinking it's physics
but we're really parasites on on or not
parasite we're not really hurting
physics we're just living on this
organisms this organism and we're like
trying to understand it but really it is
an organism and with a deep deep
intelligence maybe physics itself is
uh the the organism that's doing a super
interesting thing and we're just like
one little thing yeah ant sitting on top
of it trying to get energy from it we're
just kind of like these particles in a
wave that I feel like is mostly
deterministic and takes uh Universe from
some kind of a big bang to some kind of
a super intelligent replicator some kind
of a stable point in the universe given
these laws of physics you don't think uh
as Einstein said God doesn't play dice
so you think it's mostly deterministic
there's no Randomness in the thing I
think it's deterministic oh there's tons
of uh well I want to be careful with
Randomness pseudo random yeah I don't
like random uh I think maybe the laws of
physics are deterministic
um yeah I think they're determinants
just got really uncomfortable with this
question
do you have anxiety about whether the
universe is random or not
what's there's no Randomness uh you say
you like Goodwill Hunting it's not your
fault Andre it's not it's not your fault
man
um so you don't like Randomness uh yeah
I think it's uh unsettling I think it's
a deterministic system I think that
things that look random like say the uh
collapse of the wave function Etc I
think they're actually deterministic
just entanglement uh and so on and uh
some kind of a Multiverse Theory
something something okay so why does it
feel like we have a free will
like if I raised his hand I chose to do
this now um
what
that doesn't feel like a deterministic
thing it feels like I'm making a choice
it feels like it okay so it's all
feelings it's just feelings yeah
so when an RL agent is making a choice
is that
um
it's not really making a choice the
choices are all already there yeah
you're interpreting the choice and
you're creating a narrative for or
having made it yeah and now we're
talking about the narrative it's very
meta